I grew up in the family of skywriting
that's just a little kid that's all I
knew just like being an artist in the
sky I'm Greg Stennis and I own a company
called skytypers with my son Steven
Stennis
[Music]
my dad was one of the original sky
riders he started 1931 the one airplane
travels a big circle if he's gonna make
it no and that takes a lot of time to do
that and he decided hey there's got to
be a faster way to do this I'll just do
it with a bunch of airplanes and so he
came up with the method of skytyping
fighter airplanes flying in formation
for instance if we're gonna make an eye
everybody let's have just one puff
there's your eye if you want to turn
that into an L it's one puff and plus
the bottom guy lets out three more puffs
there's your L this is a very
specialized form of flying
most of my pilots have got a like ten
thousand flying hours so they're very
experienced you fly a a 5 B Tiger planes
when we fly it's roughly 45 minutes to
get up to altitude which is 10,000 feet
a typical skytyping message is 20
characters sometimes 25 and that's
roughly five miles length each letter is
the size of the empire statement
well-funded feet tall they're of the
biggest ads in the world and you can't
miss them the whole sky becomes your
billboard I do this because not only is
it fun cuz I love flying but I like the
accomplishment of what we do because
people we fly for and they're all
throughout
we've gotten something like a hundred
and twenty years of skywriting in the
family
my dad trained me and I've trained my
son and I'm very proud about poetry
[Music]
[Music]
just let you know that the flight team
is going to be roughly a minute and 20
seconds today
[Music]
this is Westray Island Airport and this
is Papa Wester Island Airport there are
only 1.7 miles away from each other and
are connected by the world's shortest
commercial flight
the average flying time is about 80
seconds these two islands are a part of
the Orkney Islands in northern Scotland
this archipelago is defined by jagged
coastlines and it's obvious lack of
trees there are 70 islands in total only
20 of them are inhabited on some islands
like Papa Westray the population is less
than 100 to get around up here
most people fly on this plane the
inter-island Logan air route
Collin here he's the head pilot :
McAllister I'm the senior pilot the
aircraft we fly in Orkney oh cabbies the
passengers and the highest that we'd
reach in over 350 feet altitude so it's
quite long it flies around about 150
miles an hour and it has the
aerodynamics of a brick but it's super
for what we do in the islands so why
does this flight exist because there are
so few people in the Orkney Islands
building bridges doesn't make financial
sense they just wouldn't get enough use
so if you live up here there are only
two ways to get around one you can take
this ferry which is super super slow or
two you can fly
my name is Kate and I live on top me
mainland but I fly out to several of the
islands teaching music on a weekly basis
once every three weeks and flying is
your display to get to work
the flight is used almost like a bus
service it acts like a bus route but
it's not it takes a team from the two
air traffic controllers okay that's too
clear to learn to the four firefighters
they all work together to help keep the
flight safe over the years I've flown
somewhere between four or five thousand
times between Westry and Paco Westry
it's community spirit that drives the
people who work at the airfields the
world's shortest flight has been around
for a long time
the here I've been flying it for 50
years in Orkney at this point it's a
well-oiled machine our only complaint no
drink service
[Music]
the most recognizable thing in the sky
was obviously the silhouette of the
Spitfire she's just a beautiful lady
I sure a lot of men would actually like
to marry her I'm sure they're wise
wouldn't agree there's 396 parts in a
Spitfire see how do I know that I built
it this is Martin Phillips my name is
Martin Phillips and I am sitting next to
my Spitfire RR 2 3 2 which I'm the proud
owner of Martin is obsessed with
Spitfires the big bombers join in
pounding the shoreline in the darkest
days of World War 2 Spitfires filled the
sky above England they are an icon like
freedom on wings British kids make
models of them but Martin took his
spitfire devotion to a whole nother
level for his 40th birthday
Martin's friends gave him a single
Spitfire rivet when I was presented with
this rivet the challenge was to go and
build myself a Spitfire to inspire at
the moment not thinking I said why I'll
go out on the Monday morning and I will
build a Spitfire I never thought that
over a period of 14 years but I'd
probably wear three cars outward mileage
along the journey to provide all the
parts that you now see today the fuel
tanks they came from Norway in Sweden
some of the other parts came from Russia
some of the parts came from Israel some
of the other parts came from Holland
came from France one of the wings was
offered to us through a Lost Property
Department and another wing came through
a little guy coming into work said I've
got a Spitfire wing in my garden the
man-hours that go into a project like
this don't underestimate it they are
terrific and I know the blood sweat
tears that went into that after 14 years
I know the question you're going to ask
me do you fly it sadly not I am learning
to fly and I hope one day to fly it
but at Greater guys than me fly it
my name is Matt Jones I'm a Spitfire
pilot the modern airliners fly at 85
percent the speed of sound
they got Spitfires flying at 96 97 %
speed of sound
you don't get in a Spitfire you strap it
on and it becomes a part of you because
the aeroplane means so much to so many
people there are a lot of people who
have gone down Martin's path and started
thinking they want to build a Spitfire
but I've never met anyone else who's
completed it he dedicated his life to
finding the parts he needed to get this
airplane flying again I went through
these 14 years had heartache than bits
didn't fit just putting it together and
finishing it and the provenance and the
journey the journey I went on you know
tears even today I cry when it runs it's
just been amazing absolutely amazing
[Music]
[Music]
this here is a darkling beetle it lives
out here in the vast desert of Northwest
Utah and he's on the move way or - I
don't have a clue but I can tell you
about the town he's leaving behind
welcome to loose in Utah there's
abandoned cars weeds once in a while
train will pass through yep there's not
a whole lot here and loosen well except
for this man but who is this man this
man who lives in an airplane hangar who
flies a Cessna to get to his closest
friends who is this man this man who
lives in the middle of nowhere who lives
25 miles from this bar with this man
inside who owns a bunch of guns works
with machines and made this thing
is this man my name is I've always got a
scare and this is what I live as you've
gathered this man isn't from around
loosen he grew up in Czechoslovakia
before the fall of the USSR he didn't
like it much it's kinda hard to do
anything the Communists were in power is
there you cannot have your own business
it's kind of difficult to fly there so
high camera I didn't feel like I could
be myself he really wanted to leave the
country but it wasn't easy
there was an Iron Curtain they like have
a machine gun towers and barbed wire to
keep you in they like to keep you so
when he was 24 he escaped the country
the only way he knew how
by flying across the border in his self
built airplane so I drove up close to
the border between Austria and some time
like at 3 o'clock in the morning I took
off and I just got it over to Austria
and I found myself Vienna International
Airport and I landed that and then I
just showed them my expired passport and
I asked for asylum and the world took
notice
[Music]
I guess they're never seen on this thing
like that before word it so I think they
liked it I liked it I though then moved
to Los Angeles and built up a successful
airplane propeller business but even LA
couldn't fit his big ideas I kind of
needed a place to test my other idea
which is how to do it in the middle of
the city that's how I found this place
in Utah it was for sale so I bought it
and I've been here for like eight years
yeah what was I those big idea that
brought him to loosen well it's behind
that door over there
[Music]
inside sits in a propeller flying
machine able to lift off and land
vertically it's basically an airplane
helicopter hybrid of sorts it's kind of
funny looking but the damn thing
actually flies
[Music]
so what's Ava's next big project the
solar powered aircraft an innovative
propeller design some kind of new way to
fly the next big one is that the
speargun idea army Chuck Chile it was
better than I thought that doesn't
always work that way sometime I get the
really bad ideas
[Music]
even while inventing new spear guns and
the like Ivo still finds the time to get
out of the house in fact that's him over
there
hiking on the side of a mountain it's
just him nature and his customized rifle
I think the gun was mean because of the
mountain lions
however treacherous the hike it's always
worth it you get a good view of loosen
it actually looks pretty nice from here
don't it you know I still wonder why did
that Darkman beetle ever leave this
place maybe loosen wasn't right for the
little guy maybe it's escaped into the
next place where it can be itself
Bravo though looks like this might be
his last stop come at Eliza this is what
I always wanted I kept escaping until I
escaped to listen and now I don't have
anywhere else to escape like not a study
here
[Music]
well no it's also a truce if you think
about it